one of the things that they stumbled
upon was the way people are much more
sensitive losses than the games so give
me that give which one your mug yes your
mug you like so you give me this okay so
so the the displeasure that you
experience when I take your cherished
mug I do cherish it appends yeah so
you're right aren't starting out live
it's been on every show is it yeah
everything's ledger is is much greater
than the pleasure you would experience
it like escape if I brought came in here
fresh and gave it to you that that
people people people are they respond
more extremely to gains than the losses
and and that the idea extends actually
one of their bigger points was people
actually when they're making decisions
they don't decide between things they
decide between descriptions and things
so if I describe something to you as a
game as opposed to a loss exact same
thing that you you will that will affect
the decision you make and they they test
it on doctors they came to you two
doctors with this scenario you have a
patient he's got cancer and it will kill
them in kind of seven years there's an
operation you can do on this patient you
got to do it now and they tell one set
of doctors that like if you do this
operation
there's a 90% chance that the patient
will survive the operation and they
totally all said of doctors if you do
this operation there's a 10% chance
you're gonna they're gonna die
same thing not if I'm right and if they
the doctors they told there was a nine
percent chance to survive we're twice as
likely to do the operation and then the
ones they said there's a 10% chance
they're gonna die so they just responded
the descriptive way they scientists or
doctors you know right they're the
decisions they make in a life-and-death
situation or affected by the way the
things described well it is pretty
amazing the work these two guys did and
I don't know even how why no one else is
talking about them but you earth this
story and it's a great story and a lot
of the story is what it is between these
two guys they were in love they were
it's you know I was at yes I was I was
at if we buried a headline on that one
today we're leaders so I was asked by
The Hollywood Reporter to give me a give
him the one-line movie pitch for them
for the book
and I said it's it's Brokeback Mountain
but they've each other's ideas
[Applause]
you put what either where is more
complicated
no I this is so typical with me I had
this like respectable Charlie Rose
interview going about a book in theory
and then you go right down Kathy Griffin
alley at the end what the hell why is it
what is it about this show that you if
you want Charlie Rose you wouldn't say
that between a you've enabled me to
access a part of myself I don't normally
have access yeah okay this is my current
blessing I think he just sold a lot of
books like this
you